rockets struck near kabul's
international airport this morning as
the u.s troop withdrawal enters its
final stage witnesses said the rockets
hit the salim karwan neighborhood just
north of the airport where planes
continued to evacuate military and
civilian personnel the explosions were
followed by gunfire now it is unclear
who is responsible for the attack and if
anyone was injured it comes after the
u.s carried out two airstrikes on
suspected islamist militants over the
weekend
a bombed out vehicle after more rocket
strikes near kabul's international
airport on monday
witnesses say they heard several
explosions in the afghan capital
it's not yet clear who launched the
rockets
the blasts come as the u.s military
races to complete its evacuation from
afghanistan by a tuesday deadline
amid threats of attacks on kabul's
airport
on sunday a u.s drone blew up a vehicle
carrying suspected suicide bombers
apparently on their way to the airport
the u.s says the car contained a large
amount of explosives
eyewitnesses say the drone strike hit
two cars as well as a house killing
several people
suddenly the sound of mortars came and
it was very dangerous
when we came here the cars were on fire
and some children had died and their
hands and faces were burnt
many afghans say they know the violence
and uncertainty surrounding them are
inescapable and they're eager to see
basic services operating again
some banks have reopened but the lines
are long and clients can only withdraw
limited amounts of cash
many questions remain around daily life
the last time the taliban were in power
women were banned from work
and girls from going to school
now the group says they will be allowed
but under taliban rules rules that have
yet to be made clear so many pupils are
staying home
to come to school
but no one is here in our class
there are five people in a class
we want to study in our future will be
good if we can
but the situation of our schools is very
bad
unsure of what comes next afghans
especially in the capital kabul
remain on high alert
let's get the latest from kabul now we
can speak to journalist franz marty
who's standing by hi friends good to see
you what more can you tell us about the
rocket fire around kabul airport
the rockets uh impacted like in in areas
around the airport but apparently didn't
cause um
a lot of damage or or casualties or not
that
as far as i'm aware
they have been aimed at the airport it
seems they were fired from a launcher
hidden in a car
this modus operandi is like a hallmark
of the self-declared islamic state so
far however no one has officially
claimed the responsibility it should
also be taken into account that such
rockets attacks are nothing new there
have been like several during the past
two three years um so it is not
something completely new
well the evacuations are drawing to a
close are afghans still going to the
airport to try to get out
there's still some afghans that try to
get into into the airport however
usually they try to
go
with a bus there have been like buses
organized by several evacuation flights
that then pick people up outside and are
supposed to bring them inside this
worked like until yesterday or so but
from a person
who tried to help evacuees i have heard
that like the last civilian got into the
airport yesterday and also only with a
lot of problems so now it seems to be
more or less closed but there's
still some people that hope
against all odds to make it in
and france what about the taliban in all
of this what restrictions are they
imposing on people who want to leave
so far it has been like chaotic scenes
at the airport so the taliban uh
supposedly um
uh kept only people out without uh
paperwork but there have been like many
instances reported where like even even
passport holders afghans with a foreign
passport were not let through by the
taliban
um after the attack they pushed the
parameter further away and uh let him
less people in if at all um so there
have been reports that they uh
like double checked like manifests uh on
on these buses that really only people
who are on lists inside get in this is a
stark contrast to the to to before when
practically everyone just like tried how
it will be in the future remains to be
seen the taliban have time and time
again assured that people with valid
travel documents can also leave the
country after the evacuation uh
concludes
journalist franz marti reporting there
from kabul thank you
germany's foreign minister is on a tour
of countries neighboring afghanistan to
shore up support for continued
evacuations on monday he visited the
uzbek capital tashkent where he
announced that uzbekistan is willing to
open its borders to evacuees who will
then be flown to germany the german
government says there are more than ten
thousand people who still need to be
evacuated from afghanistan massa's trip
includes stops in tajikistan later today
and pakistan tomorrow
and dw correspondent nick connolly is
following the talks in tashkent for us
today hi nick
what is the situation like at the border
are a lot of afghans trying to flee into
uzbekistan right now
well potentially there are tens of
thousands of afghans who would you want
to use this route because from where
they are in the north of afghanistan
places like mazar sharif kunduz
these neighboring countries like
uzbekistan
are far closer than kabul and they'd
have far fewer taliban checkpoints to
get through for now not many have been
let through mainly people who already
had visas people
largely kind of upper middle class
people politicians people who had
well-connected mainly people from the
uzbek ethnic minority in afghanistan
there was a big moment on 14th of august
when mazan sharif fell to the taliban
and basically the whole military
leadership of that town tried to get
over to uzbekistan but only a handful
were actually led in permanently so
there's a real demand here from people
even i've only been a few days and
already um inundated with requests from
people friends of friends trying to find
a way out of afghanistan through
uzbekistan but not getting a chance so
far well we know that germany germany
only managed to get around 5 300 people
out of afghanistan in time but there are
a lot more people on a list to be
evacuated so what is next for them
so we heard from haikon mars today that
they would be doing their best to try
and uh start charter flights and
non-military flights out of kabul that's
obviously pretty uncertain given a the
technical side of things the fact that
the radar systems in kabul have been
largely destroyed and all that's been
taken over by the u.s military who are
leaving imminently then there's
obviously the security situation how
people are even going to get to that
airport and if as i've mentioned there
in the north of the country getting
there is a pretty precarious journey
and on which the western countries that
often employ these people can do
precious little to help people actually
achieve it in safety and then that
second option opening these land borders
but the uzbek government is very very
careful and is worried on the one hand
of
straining relations with the taliban
next door that they're going to have to
work with and secondly of turning into
basically essentially a refugee camp for
europe they are very certain and very
clear that this is only going to be
about transit and they're not going to
let people stay in large numbers for the
long term
how do uzbeks feel about afghans fleeing
to their country
well there's been a lot of criticism
here on social media of the government
especially when it comes to ethnic
uzbeks from afghanistan uh ordinary
citizens here feeling the government has
been too slow and too
parsimonious in terms of handing out
visas
but equally there is also fear of
contagions at work from afghanistan
destabilization the government here is
very worried about islamism political
islam and there is that worry that if
you know this country is destabilized by
a large influx of people then the
political situation here could get more
difficult so pretty contradictory
feelings but definitely a feeling for
many ordinary respects that this country
could be doing more
dw's nick connolly reporting from
tashkent good to talk to you